comic-con has always been a place where
people can put aside their everyday
identities and dress up as the
characters they love and that's
certainly the case with my special guest
he's a leading Democratic presidential
contender but this week this week he's
just another diehard fan of the My
Little Pony Friendship is Magic cartoon
series please welcome brony Sanders
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there it is thank you
Comic Con or thank you Conan for having
me on your show it is is my absolute
pleasure senator Sanders pleats Connick
I don't respond to that name here I am
junebug a pony who made her first
appearance in season 2 of My Little Pony
and I bring greetings from America
learned of a clustering all right
okay well June Bug how are things in
Equestria deplorable the top one-tenth
of 1% of ponies owns as much horse meal
and sugar cubes as the blood of Millie
deeper circus do we want to live in a
nation where rich ponies like diamond
tiara and silver spoon get richer while
hardworking ponies like Rainbow Dash
falling for death because they did not
have access to quality hoof care no I
same day I did you
did you say I'm sorry I'm sorry did you
say hoof care I promise that I will not
negotiate with tyrants like Queen
chrysalis or King Sombra I will expose
the treachery of bad actors in elements
like cozy glow who revealed her true
colors when she betrayed the cutie crow
in season 8 episode 40 okay okay that's
fine all right this crowd like that yeah
I gotta say you uh you lost me on that
one senators and June ball right I'm
sorry June bug good luck on your
campaign sir finally Conan
here is my promise to the equestrian
people when a budget that includes free
college tuition is presented to me I
will sign that budget provided that the
budget is presented to me on the flat of
your palm from an angle that does not
make me skittish and make me want to
rear back and kick somebody who's
standing behind me in that case I will
sorry yes Bernie Sanders everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was game cotillion everybody and
he's a genius
[Applause]